this place is so nice this is supposed
to be one of the best French places in
town hmm I did not realize that you were
so cultured you're sweet
my French is pretty good so I can order
for both of us
oh sure welcome to shade ellenmilton
Ventura I am your waiter for this
evening my name is jean-luc de la piel
notes but you make initial moles or zone
will be any questions about anything at
all I'm more than happy to assist you
Jean I got it
merci beaucoup que bien
well our first special tonight is our
Poisson du jour is a Loup de mer bleue
of a song served with a puny avert du
cochon de permit that is served on a bed
of gendarme - Felisa Oh pal and also
serve a Lumina crush and souffle petit a
Fiat or DuPont green yay
YUM our soup today is the Palermo salt
with just a dash of Shannon Brown and
served with melted pistol Tasha back to
a few so yeah our other seafood today we
have a very nice Flint on par on the
possible from the good source of alien
visitor it is served with a side of
Colombo fotona
de la mota do God come here
Cologne sauce oh I'm so glad you said
that I was about to say this you
recommend getting me from Punk Avant
Dumpty plump Isabella with the I'm sorry
it's the political ad the piece a of a
law and a heavy falls on thought sauce
oh no no no it's more like a caution to
come to cultivar sauce what do you think
I'm I'm gonna defer to him on this one
because he knows this stuff away better
than I do it's miss you
yeah well we'll have the Thunder and
what's had it through there for a lot of
awesome it's been nice knowing you have
a lovely dinner